my man Simon Cowell is a matter of fact
he told me how he could take this
isolation thing to an extreme is this
the longest stretch of time you've been
home ever
yes yeah it was difficult at first
because you know I don't have a
telephone for instance so for three
years how does that work Simon very
simple one morning I woke up and I've
got 52 unread messages and I realized it
was actually stopping me from working or
living properly so I just turned it off
and I loved it
well we already knew Simon doesn't phone
anything in especially when it comes to
getting fit the 60 year old AGT judge
lost 60 pounds in one year and even in
quarantine he's committed to his
regiment likely doing my exercises I've
got a pretty good routine going
Simon kicks off season 15 of America's
Got Talent tonight on NBC with Sofia
vegara joining the panel some episodes
were shot before production shut down
due to Cova 19 but simon says plans for
the final live shows are still up in the
air
I don't think gonna be with 3,000 people
I think that that is not going to happen
this year whatever we need to do we will
get to the end of the finals this year
there will be a winner let's talk about
Heidi for a second she also there was
concerned that she might have Kobe 19
I'm feeling good so that's why I've
stayed home to not infect any other
people well it was terrifying because it
was in the really really early stages I
mean we've been decision join me which
is until you know whether you've got it
or not
you can't come to work she did the right
thing in the meantime Simon and
six-year-old son Eric are living a dream
come true
they've got cameos in the new scooby-doo
movie Scoob
on the day that we turned out to do the
recording he was actually directing me
daddy I wouldn't say it that way that
doesn't sound like you I'm like my god
you turned into a director already
[Music]